wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
also erzähl mal wie geht's denn mit
seiner brücke voran und du meinst die
brücke für den wettbewerb ich habe
ziemlich viel zu tun
trotzdem bin ich schon weiter gekommen
investor zu bringen
noch nicht ganz aber ich hatte die idee
solarzellen an dieser in zu montieren
die können die lampen auf der brücke
damit strom versorgen
das waren ein paar andere gut und machen
jetzt mit kohl ich finde alternative
energien sowieso am interessantesten
auch in architektur man kann auch an
gebäuden viel energie sparen ist es zu
spannend ja ich habe neulich einen
artikel über intelligente häuser gelesen
es mag es gar nicht hier neuen wörter
oder phrasen gleich hallo ich will auch
gar nicht lange stören aber wenn ich
dich jetzt gerade sehe was gibt's dann
ich will für morgen einen kleinen
flohmarkt für flüchtlinge organisieren
dann gebrauchte sachen fahrräder
klamotten wenn
irgendwas hat dass ihr nicht mehr
braucht dann bringt es gerne vorbei naja
das ist eine super idee ich sag gleich
meinen schülern bescheid und du deine
eltern ja auf jeden fall das ist echt
sehr nett vielen dank entschuldigung ja
gemacht sind
nicos selber freut mich dann sehen wir
uns morgen danke also selber du und nico
was ist denn da los